we're using taxpayers money to save
bankers not exactly a popular concept
among citizens sasha stefan joins us now
he's a professor at the european school
of management and technology here in
berlin it's good to have you with us
well first of all as a banking expert
how let's say unpopular do you feel at
times
i actually don't feel very unpopular i
think so that people are actually not
blaming me for things that are going
which are currently going on but rather
come to me and ask specific questions to
understand exactly what's happening and
try basically to to boil down the
complexity of this whole situation well
let's let's try and boil it down a bit
now i mean five years after the big
bailouts the big crisis what's the
situation like for european banks now
yeah i think the situation is better
than it has been a couple of years ago
but it's still a long way to go i mean
if you look at for example the variation
of the company it's still
um below 50 percent or 60
60 per euro so that's this means that
there's significant amount of risk still
in the balance sheets where we have to
take care of like
what do you say uh significant amount of
risks in the balance sheet uh do we have
a figure for that already uh we don't
have exact figure but i mean there's a
lot of things which are going on on the
one hand there's a sovereign debt which
is a big issue right now there's a lot
of bad loans which are on the balance
sheets particularly of the peripheral
banks but also on german and european
other european banks as well now i mean
obviously uh some uh 200 124 european
banks will have to undergo the so-called
stress test now in spring and and summer
and a lot will depend on whether
the government bonds the banks holding
government bonds whether that will be
taken into account because some say
there's no risk at all others like the
ceo of commerce bank says absolutely
these bonds do harbor risks what's your
take i absolutely agree with mr blessing
and i think two days ago we had a new
information from the ecb where they made
the clear point that sovereign debt is
risky and so we have to treat this as a
risky investment and i think this is the
hope that the actual the risks of the
sovereign debt is in some way figured
into the outcome of the stress test this
year okay what if the outcome of the
stress test shows that some major banks
maybe also systemic relevant banks uh
can't meet the financial requirements
what then
so first of all they have to try to
raise um equity in and private capital
markets then there might be a bailin of
some subordinate debt holders but i
think then there has to be some sort of
public that stop
so there is substantial amount of
of of debt of bonds in the balance
sheets of the banks which could be used
and transferred into and or converted
into equity but if this is not
sufficient then there has to be uh
definitely taxpayer estate money as a
backstop for these banks whatever
happened to the idea that banks pay into
a rescue fund in order to save
themselves this is a very good idea but
it's still the 55 billion which people
are talking about is is very basically
very little compared to the balance
sheet and potential capital shortfalls
of these banks plus um it takes a
significant amount of time until this
fund is actually available so this is a
clear indication that there needs to be
some public money as a backstory okay
well it looks like there's still a long
way to go for banks to be on a sound
footing stefan thank you very much for
being here